bonsoir pezens maison merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france cette crise politique
en suède
pour bien comprendre quelle en est la
cause au fond de cause d'une course
d'institutionnels et une cause qui tient
à la situation du logement souhaite la
cause institutionnelle c'est que un
parti d'extrême gauche à la gauche les
sociaux démocrates est apparue et avec à
sa tête maintenant une femme très
médiatique qui veut sa place dans la lah
dans la vie politique suédoise et puis à
l'extrême droite un parti qui est
surtout caractérisée par son sac
xénophobie et par sa volonté de lutter
contre toute immigration qui fait des
scores importants dans les sondages qui
par conséquent gagne en importance et il
se trouve que ces deux partis extraits
des textes et des deux extrêmes se sont
combinés au combiné leurs actions pour
faire chuter le gouvernement de monsieur
nouvelle alors bien sûr il y avait en
embuscade
le parti de droite traditionnel
le parti libéral qui dans le chef a dit
au même moment que dans le fond il
faudrait maintenant passer un à une
alternance avec un premier ministre de
droite puisque ça fait sept ans que
monsieur levens et premier ministre
qu'il représente la gauche sociale
démocrate alors le deuxième raison c'est
évidemment la raison de fond c'est la
politique de logement il se trouve que
les loyers en suède sont bloqués ou
presque bloquée depuis 1940 ils sont en
tout cas administrés et que ceux ci a
deux conséquences
une pénurie de logements dans les
grandes villes il faut attendre une
dizaine d'années avant d'avoir accès à
un logement à prix régulés et puis bien
entendu ça aussi comme deuxième
conséquence le fait que ceux qui ont la
chance d'avoir un de ces logements à
prix régulés sont fortement tenté de le
soulever a appris beaucoup beaucoup plus
élevé par conséquent les
dysfonctionnements importants dans la
politique du logement
et comme il l'avait promis aux partis
de droite au parti libéral monsieur
levens a donc proposé une loi qui
permettrait de libéraliser les loyers
des nouveaux logements donc seulement
les nouveaux logements ce qui est une
réforme assez limité puisque dans un
premier temps - ça ne toucherait pas les
anciens logements alors c'est sur ce
sujet que la présidente du parti
d'extrême gauche a dit que c'était tout
à fait inacceptable et que par
conséquent elles voteraient la motion de
censure qui étaient mises sur la table
du parlement pour d'autres raisons par
le parti d'extrême droite comme
blanchemaison que va-t-il se passer
maintenant en suède
et bien comme vous l'avez dit dans votre
sujet maintenant c'est le président du
parlement qui a la main et qui doit
trouver un nouveau premier ministre
susceptible de réunir 175 voix c'est à
dire la majorité du parlement et il a
pour ce faire
là le devoir de consulter bien sûr tous
les partis y compris d'ailleurs le
premier ministre sortant qui expédie les
affaires courantes et qui pourrait lui
aussi être chargé à nouveau de former un
gouvernement mais aussi d'essayer de
trouver des combinaisons qui assurent
ses 175 voix il a pour ce faire quatre
possibilité de choisir un premier
ministre successivement il a donc droit
à quatre essais et s'il n'y arrive pas
eh bien à ce moment là évidemment la
dissolution est inévitable alors cette
dissolution c'est un petit peu insolite
parce que la constitution suédoise a une
particularité c'est qu'elle prévoit des
élections législatives à terme fixe et
donc il ya un terme qui est prévue en
2022 2018 2022
et s'il devait y avoir une dissolution
et bien ce sera une élection
supplémentaires mais qui ne ferait pas
courir un nouveau délai de quatre ans un
nouvel essai tueur de la législature
n'aurait qu'un peu plus d'un an devant
elle
donc je pense que les parties vont tout
faire pour essayer d'éviter cela est
effectivement là
il ya une hypothèse qui jusqu'à présent
était repoussée par les par la plupart
des partis de gouvernement en suède qui
est l'hypothèse d'une alliance entre la
droite classique le centre et l'extrême
droite
mais il n'est pas sûr encore une fois
que cette formule puisse fonctionner l
aspect de c'est un pays à part au sein
de l'europe on s'en est rendu compte à
plusieurs reprises pour quelles raisons
mais d'abord elle avait fait route
commune avec la grande-bretagne en
participant à l'association européenne
de libre échange et puis finalement peu
de temps après la la grande bretagne
après le royaume uni elle a décidé de
rejoindre l'union européenne
elle est entrée dans l'union européenne
en janvier 1995 et depuis cette époque
elle est un bon membre de l'union
européenne mais elle n'a pas voulu
rentrer dans le système monétaire unique
il n'a pas voulu prendre l'euro comme
monnaie unique elle a gardé sa monnaie
nationale
par ailleurs elle a des liens très
étroits traditionnelle avec les autres
pays nordiques
deux sont également membres de l'union
européenne
c'est la finlande et le danemark ne le
sont pas c'est l'islande et la norvège
et par conséquent ces pays ont une
coopération avec un certain nombre de
sujets techniques sur laquelle ils ont
les projets qu'il mène en commun et puis
enfin la suède
néna n'a pas la volonté d'adhérer dans
l'otan et lorsqu'on lui pose la question
lorsque le secrétaire général le temps
les pose la question
elle répond non nous voulons bien une
coopération avec le temps mais nous
n'adhérons pas l'otan car nous ne
voulons pas laisser la finlande isolé
toujours est il que dans les débats au
sein du conseil européen
la suède a souvent une position
singulière elle fait partie des pays
frigo c'est à dire des pays qui sont
opposés à l'emprunt de 750 milliards
d'euros qui a été décidé
l'année dernière parce que elle trouvait
dangereux cette communautarisation d'une
partie de la dette des états membres cet
effort de solidarité avec une innovation
institutionnelle qui ne lui plaisait pas
et elle est partisan de la rigueur
budgétaire
et puis la semaine dernière au conseil
européen elle fait partie des six ou
sept pays qui se sont opposés à l'idée
d'une reprise un dialogue structuré avec
la russie donc elle à elle elle a pris
le parti de la pologne et les trois pays
baltes pour s'y opposer
certains voient là un roman historique
de 1509 date à laquelle la suède le
royaume dessus elle a perdu une bataille
contre pierre le grand mais c'est quand
même bien ancien merci et que pense
maison expert en relations
internationales